[Music]
good evening governor sissel act
changing the state's plan to get
kobach's
vaccines to more nevadans thanks for
joining us here at six i'm denise valdez
and i'm christian casares nevada is
doing away with the tears we've been
talking about for a while
instead a new strategy will help our
state adjust
to the reality leaders are facing
joining us live to break everything down
everything down in this plan is vanessa
murphy
[Music]
yeah so nevada was going with the tiered
approach with
healthcare workers at the top but listen
to the numbers that were just released
nevada has received 170 000
doses of the vaccine so far with only
about
61 000 administered governor siselek and
his team are saying they want more
people vaccinated
they say they want a better system and
they've developed it
they want to get that vaccine to seniors
and vulnerable
populations so take a look i want to
show you from this
new playbook there are two lanes instead
of that tiered approach
the essential workforce lane and the
general population
you can see on the left the front line
and community
safety workers educators behind them and
it goes on
then the other lane the general
population starts with nevadans
70 and older it continues down to
seniors
those with underlying health conditions
so again this is nevada's new
system to get more people vaccinated the
state knew this was coming though
i asked governor sisilek about the delay
in developing a plan like this
it seems that nevada is behind other
states though in getting the vaccine out
states which are much larger larger seem
to have a better hold than we do
why is this since we have known that
we would need a vaccination plan and why
has it taken so long
to come up with this newer playbook well
it hasn't taken
so long vanessa really come up with it
you know we've been planning this for a
long time we did not have the resources
nevada simply does not have the dollars
the monetary resources in order to set
up plans
like some of the other states do but i
think if you look at the total
percentage of vaccines that we've given
out
as it relates to other states i'm i'm
not satisfied but i'm proud of
everything that our frontline workers
have done
governor sislek blamed the federal
government several times
saying the state only finds out how many
doses it's getting
the week before it actually gets those
doses
so i know our viewers want to know when
they will be able to get vaccinated that
question was asked
at this point we do not have dates but
we will certainly
keep asking and let our viewers know
we've received some call for
from some calls from seniors again we
will let them know but at this point the
state is not releasing
an exact timeline or date when it will
be available
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now